hello and welcome back to
coffee with kennel i am sean cannell and
in this episode we're actually going to
be talking about
how to go full-time make a full-time
living and earn a full-time wage
from youtube even if you have a small
audience and we're going to be talking
about
the concept of 1 000 true
fans and so buckle your seat belt we've
got some powerful
um content to share and if you're new to
coffee with kennel
during the first 15 minutes i've got
some structured teaching if you want to
watch that first part on the replay and
then during the second
half of the show i bring you on to
answer your questions
about youtube social media online
business and really how to scale and
grow your
income and your influence faster with
video
and so let's just dive right into it
um but uh here we go so
today's topic is 1 000 true fans how to
make a full-time living on youtube
with a small audience and let me know if
you're watching this have you already
started a youtube channel and what is
your youtube channel about now today's
episode is brought to you by
talk with think dot com
link in the description below and we'll
post a link in the comments as well
um if you ever want to get in touch with
us at think media
because you've moved into a time in your
life and your business and your brand
where you're
serious and you want to start
accelerating and maybe learn more about
some of our courses
or our monthly coaching program or any
of our events
talk with think is the place to do it
you can schedule a 15-minute call
with somebody from the think media team
and we will figure out
if um and how we can help you reach your
goals
faster and so that is how
today is brought to you if you're
watching live wendy
antonia frills good to see you walter
let's keep going so here's the question
how can i make a living on youtube
without a huge following
like how is it possible to make a living
off of youtube and this could be true
for anything i mean podcasting social
media we are living in the new economy
the internet right where the ability to
have an online business to make money
online
but the question is oh man is it only
for those with a million subscribers
is it only for those that have a hundred
thousand subscribers is it possible to
earn a full-time living
if i don't have a huge audience and the
answer is yes and
if you haven't heard about the concept
of a thousand true fans this is
a critical teaching to understand
back in 2008 kevin kelly wrote an
article
and an essay about a thousand true fans
and this
is what the premise is
to be a successful creator you don't
need millions you don't need millions of
dollars you don't need millions of
customers you don't need millions of
clients you don't need millions of fans
and that is the myth that influencer
kind of marketing has told us ah
i gotta be just super famous oh i need a
million subscribers
to hit a tipping point of making enough
money with like youtube ad
cents and youtube ads and that actually
is kind of true
if that's how you're going to make money
but in this very video we're going to
pull back the curtain of how
tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands of micro influencers like you
and me
can actually go full time and make a
living the article says as a
craftsperson a photographer
a musician a designer an author an
animator
an app maker an entrepreneur or an
inventor
online you just need 1 000 true fans
you know my friend and one of the
speakers at our recent event growth
video wrote a book called super fans
it sort of was inspired by this very
essay from 2008 over 12 years
ago and it's still true today highly
recommended book by the way pat flynn
super fans
and one thing people were doing let me
know in the comments if you were part of
our
virtual conference recently growth video
live he trained on that
and um be watching the recordings and
next week we're going to be letting you
know if you missed it how you can get
access
it was really more than just conference
recording because it's really a workshop
step by step
of uh how to build a real business
with video but spock talking about a
thousand
true fans let's break down the math
one way to think about this is imagine
you create something to sell
all right just think about it as
anything right now you create
some merch uh you sell a sweatshirt you
create a digital product
um you you do uh
coaching online in some in some way
people pay you via paypal
um you create a mug you know the rise
and grind mug
for example uh it could be anything and
so follow me
this is you've got a a small audience
now you may have ten thousand youtube
subscribers
you may have three 000 youtube
subscribers using youtube as an example
not all of them are going to be true
fans what's the definition of a true fan
well a true fan is someone who's so into
what you're doing
passionate about your content passionate
about your brand
that if you release something they're
all in and let me know if there's
somebody like that for you in the
comments i know today
when it comes to music a lot of us
probably just stream music and maybe buy
less or no music like we used to but i
grew up buying cds
right i grew up buying uh tapes back in
the day
in fact the first concert i ever went to
and the first band i was a true fan of
was new kids on the block i may be
ashamed to admit
come on step by step ooh baby
gonna get to you girl okay
i shouldn't be saying does anybody
remember new kids on the block
i had all five new kids on the block
tapes
i think there was five main ones i had
the barbies that sounds
like that sounds awesome like the dolls
would like the stage
like i was a fan of new kids on the
block
you know fast forward and there's been
many bands i'm a fan of
and so guess what if they came to town i
would buy a ticket to the concert if
they released a sweatshirt or a hoodie
or a shirt i would buy the shirt
so let me know nathaniel goes what did i
just walk into and so
some people are maybe a casual listener
of a certain band
and they listen to that band online
other people are true fans if that
person comes to their area they might
get on a
on a plane they might fly to go listen
to
an artist uh or support them whatever it
takes
right now today these days i'm becoming
a super fan
of certain uh running brands i'm really
into running so i'm really getting into
asics
and like i'm obsessed with different
types of asics running shoes as i'm into
um asics and so i don't just
necessarily buy one pair of shoes a year
now i'm like trying different ones
so asics can count on me to pay them
at least like a hundred dollars a year
like
i just got some dyna flight threes those
are a hundred
i just found the nova blast shoes and i
actually bought them from a different
website but it's all gonna track back to
asics so i'm spending at least 100 200
300
a year on asics with my running habit
and i'm this fan
of asic shoes what are you a super fan
or a true fan of
that whatever you're following they
release something new they release
something cool
and you're all in with it tyler woods
he's got 28 pairs of shoes you know i
mean
vgs life's like yeah new kids on the
block i was all in with joey come on
i remember joey and so so think about
um something you're a super a super fan
of now
let's say you got 5 000 youtube
subscribers 10 000 youtube subscribers
a portion of them are the people who
really connect with you
got it so when you've got a thousand
true fans that means when you release
something you put something out into the
world they're like man i i
get her i get him i'm all in so
they're gonna buy the thing that you
sell that's the point
so imagine you had a 37 product for
example
over one year's time you've got 12
months to do this
okay you sell 83 units per month
through youtube through going live
through facebook live whatever you're
doing through podcasting
that's 2.7 per day that would be a
37 000 a year income
now that is roughly a teacher's income
here in the united states where i'm
streaming from and recording this right
now
so for example fly ride
who's one of our video ranking academy
and inner circle students
he actually has a hoodie on his
teespring now i understand there's fees
i get it there i understand like
but just go with me for a second it
costs 38.99 to buy
that hoodie all right fly ride autumn
automotive lighting
now let's say he is actually going to do
a merch drop what is that when you
release a limited line
of merch until it sells out and then
it's gone
let's say you did that just four times a
year
you did a summer fall winter spring
merch release now this could be journals
right this could be a lot of different
things all right and hit like if you're
getting value out of the uh
training so far let's even say you're
going to make 25
profit from it because again you you use
like a teespring or some kind of a
a t-shirt print house print on demand
and and
i maybe it's not that just follow me
okay you with me
so you're gonna do four one thousand
unit merch drops a year spring
summer fall winter so that means you're
a thousand true fans you're a thousand
super fans
they're going to buy that out and you're
going to profit 25
000 in spring 25 000 in summer
25 000 and fall on 25 000 in winter do
you see how powerful that is
that is a 100 000 a year
income from
um putting
a product selling something as a creator
to your super fans with your 3 000
subscribers 7
000 you might be saying sean i'm just
starting well this is something to build
up to but here's the good news
you don't have to get a million
subscribers or 100 000 or even 50 000
for this to be super practical and i'm
going to be sharing some examples
so buckle your seat belt because we're
the rabbit hole goes deeper
and i just broke down a 100 000
a year income which is pretty
extraordinary especially
to have a life on your own terms freedom
imagine this is all you did in a year
now in the year
you get to make videos go live dm people
back
post on social media biz dev with brands
email people
go to events connect collaborate
this is the way you're earning money
like all you got to do
is sell uh you know 2.7
units a day as we described in in the
prior one to potentially make like 30
to 40 to 100k a year powerful right
now it is my belief that while there are
cool things to sell like you could do
merch you could try and get people
really pumped about your
rise and grind coffee cups it could be
anything
that there is something that i believe
for youtube
creators and entrepreneurs
at large that the best industry to get
in and the best product to sell
is digital products specifically
online courses and here's why forbes did
an article
this is kind of an older article now
that said e-learning that means people
that want to learn things
online through online courses
is climbing to a 325
billion dollar a year industry by 2025.
so if you want to know what's the next
thing sean what's happening
in the next five years what's the next
wave it's this
now this research came out before
the lockdown and the pandemic so this
number has only gone up
we're seeing e-learning online learning
digital learning explode across
the planet and people are looking for
this does include universities colleges
that have online courses
but this also includes even if you look
at this article they mention things like
lynda.com which is now linkedin learning
udemy
skillshare as well as the ability to
maybe host your own online course with
teachable thinkific kajabi i know i'm
throwing a lot of things at you there
but this is the e-learning industry and
i believe
that online education that packaging
promoting and profiting from your
knowledge is the best
thing you could do as a youtube creator
but let me state a few other important
beliefs
i believe that when you're positioning
yourself on youtube
there's really two big categories
there's entertainment
and there's education entertainment is
someone i want to be a famous vlogger
i want to be a comedian amazing
but that doesn't lend itself as much
to positioning yourself to create an
online course however
if you plant your flag in a niche of
education
it could be helping people learn how to
do woodworking it could be people
helping
learn how to do quilts um and quilting
and
sewing it could be helping people create
music it could be helping people learn
guitar or piano
it could be helping people learn social
media or digital marketing if you have a
an education-based youtube channel it
actually
leads perfectly into monetizing
your knowledge and monetizing your
content through an online course
really well in fact talking to people
from thinkific i was at a conference
before the lockdown
march 1st 2020 around that time
before things really started locking
down and i was talking to thinkific and
they said this
youtube creators are their
uh most successful users because they
have a
platform that lets you host your online
course and we'll put a list
of some of our top recommendations in
the description of
this coffee with cannell episode on our
think marketing youtube channel
and but think if it was a good one and
they said that they're most successful
and it makes sense because if someone's
discovering you they're trying to learn
a foreign language they're trying to
learn a particular skill
they're trying to learn skateboarding
people do this and how to increase
your jump and learn basketball skills or
learn soccer
online learning as people are locked
down
is this massive industry and it's the
best way to make a full-time living
with a small channel or a small audience
all you need is one thousand true fans
and let's go a little bit deeper and
look at a couple
examples so this is one of our students
mccain dogs
they have actually a brick and mortar
70 employee dog training business in
canada
right where you can bring them their
dogs your dogs to them
they've also got a very successful
youtube channel mid-size though when i
say very successful it's not a million
subscribers it's not half a million
and they've packaged their knowledge
though just as one stream of income into
their business
and a course called my dog can online
dog training
and you're able to get a step-by-step
instruction
from a professional dog trainer in an
online
course now again if that course
is let's say a hundred dollars then
and they have a thousand true fans from
their 30 000 subscriber
youtube channel that can't be there
locally with their business
they could earn an extra 100 000 a year
from selling that online course in a
12-month period of time
is that crazy and that's just using this
rounded number of a hundred thousand
dollars
per year here's another example you
remember flywright he's got the hoodie
well this is a much we talked about it
earlier as merch
so he's a part of our inner circle
monthly coaching program
and his channel is about learn the what
how and why of auto lighting like
creating custom
um headlights for your import cars and
whatnot
and he's actually packaged created an
online course lightingcourse.com
five months to five figures of how to
build lights as a side hustle
so what he's actually training people to
do
is learn how to uh purchase
the raw materials or to purchase lights
and flip them online
and i've got another friend locally here
in vegas that is
is doing the same kind of he's got like
a little where he started in his garage
and he started like flipping auto parts
and whatnot so
a lot of times the way people are doing
this and this is how you can rise above
recession and really recession-proof
your business
you can take what you do in your
business
if you're a business owner and also
package
like how you do it in an online course
to create an extra stream of income
and youtube is the best place to
position your business and your brand
to do so so this began chris has got
things like
youtube ads affiliate marketing the
ability to actually
create these custom lights
and build the lights and flip lights and
actually earn money from it
but he also is creating a course on how
he
does it or how you can do it too and
earn money from it and creating an
extra stream of income around it see how
powerful this is
let me know what your aha moment so far
from this training and how this could
apply to your channel and your brand in
the comments below
here is a place called udemy not
necessarily
a place where i recommend you host your
course but it is a public online course
marketplace
and you can see people doing things like
complete guitar system
uh how you know how to play guitar and
these are online courses that cost like
twelve dollars
um or to two hundred dollars for
different
lectures and training so you can learn
how to play guitar
online so what's the skill or a passion
that you could teach and let's actually
look for a second
what are people making online courses
about if we actually go to udemy
let's check out something like like uh
using lighting design to transform your
home and i didn't whip that end of
nowhere i just i looked this up earlier
so here's an online course
for how to use lighting design to
transform
your home so you're going to learn three
layers of light to create a cohesive
dramatic lighting screen
scheme in any room it's two hours of
video
it's eight articles there's some
downloadable resources
so this is going to teach people in to
how to use lighting to do interior
design
like a pro this course is 94.99
and udemy actually tells us how many
students this course has
so there's actually 6170 students in
this online course
so if we look at 94.99
in the lifetime of this course being out
and it was updated recently so i'm not
sure when it was first created
let's just multiply that by how many
students are inside of the course
we can see that this course has earned
586 088
let me let me say that again that's over
half
a million dollars from selling an online
course that erica here
created do you see how powerful that is
and here's what i want to encourage you
with
i know that might get you pumped you're
like half a million what are we
talking about like there is such a
powerful long tail to this
to where people are earning and what i
mean by long tail is some people are
earning multiple millions a year
a million a year multiple six figures a
year but some people are earning
an extra thirty thousand dollars a year
five thousand dollars a year an extra
two grand a year
in addition to multiple streams of
income monetizing their influence
their youtube channel and their
knowledge
this is the best way to go
full time with a small audience
there's critical elements to succeeding
at this
and to really breaking through the noise
but what i want you to see
is literally how powerful this can be
let's look at just another quick example
here if we talk about
drawing let's talk about drawing a skill
of drawing and you think about maybe all
these different parents all these people
that are at home that maybe want uh to
help their
kids learn how to draw and let's just
kind of dig even deeper let's go
not at the top result let's let's look
at something
a little bit deeper down here how to
draw cute cartoon characters okay
great so we look at this and it's a
54.99
online course now picture you have a
youtube channel you're creating
uh free content on there you're learning
how to grow your youtube channel
and you're you're building up fans in
general and some of those people become
true fans they're like hey y'all
i got a course out if you want to go
check it out here's the link or links in
the description below
and there's lots of different key skills
to learn
in order to market promote
and sell your online course but that
conversation is for another day
so this course costs 54.99 and there's
15
210 students in this particular course
that's 836
000 that this course has
earned i don't know about you but that
is kind of
a jaw drop moment like wow this is nuts
i could package promote
and profit from what i know this is how
i can turn my passion
into profit and pairing youtube
with an education-based youtube channel
and packaging your knowledge in an
online course is critical
now i understand there is a lot of
different questions
and there's plenty of pitfalls that
people fall into that get them stuck
when it comes to this
and that's a lot about what our channel
think marketing and our think marketing
podcast is about
so make sure you subscribe to the think
marketing youtube channel the think
marketing podcast
and remember that we're also we do have
some accelerators like our monthly
coaching program that does
help you with this but let's look at um
a couple quick examples and then i'm
going to bring some guests on the show
so let's say just to make this simple
you've got
an online course that's 97 okay
i know it could be cheaper it could be
more expensive there's a large range
and so if you wanted to earn 97 000
a year you would only need to sell 1 000
of these
a year and let me say it again this is
assuming now
this is not you probably at this point
side hustling anymore
this isn't like man i got to go to work
and then build my use this is
like all year long i get it you gotta
get do the kids
and you got the other things you know
happening in your life's
responsibilities
but could you live off 97 000 a year let
me know in the comments like could you
live off that
could that be a good starting point for
you or maybe
maybe you've got 22 kids and you live in
the center of manhattan
and you couldn't because you're like i
mean that's 97 is not going to cut it
where my cost of living but for probably
a lot of us depending on where we are
uh in the world 97 000 a year
might be a great income or a good
baseline so let me know
so imagine being able to devote your
full focus
to serving people creating content
building your marketing your messaging
and all those types of things right
you could do this right 97 course
a thousand a year but let's be super
practical
like even really practical and say you
know in year one
at the end of the year you could only
sell 250.
and all your hustle you're still
learning you're still studying you're
leveling up
dialing in your message even dialing in
your course whatever it is
if in year one you only sold 250 that
would be 24
250 and maybe that's a side hustle year
man i got stuff to do i got my main job
i'm doing this on the weekends i'm
working on some other stuff i'm building
this stuff out
can you see how practical that could be
and then of course
you get better at the skill set of
packaging
promoting and profiting from your
knowledge online so in year two
man you sell 500. so now you had a 50
000
year now keep in mind that when you're
doing this
in particular on youtube you might also
have some affiliate links in the
description of some videos
you're also making youtube ads off the
viewership of your videos
you might even have a brand that wants
to work with you and they want to pay
you to make a video
because there's a lot of different ways
you can create income streams
so this is just the income from your
course so you might make
50k in that year that second year on
your online course
but then you might make another 5k and
youtube ads or 15k in affiliate
marketing and it really can snowball
with all the multiplicity of ways there
is to earn money in the new economy
and then number three like year three
you got this thing dialed in like give
yourself
three years to get better learn the
skills
level up do you see how powerful that
would be
and even if you're going what you would
perceive as
slower than somebody else like i think
about how much time i
took me to learn this i mean by now
we've actually earned
multiple seven figures in online courses
uh through think media but there was
years where i was
just investing in courses and going to
events
and watching trainings like this one and
still trying to figure out being like
dude i got a million questions
and it takes time like it definitely is
what
what i hear about in this industry is
the easy myth like
i'm not trying to make this look overly
easy i'm not trying to say it's easy
i'm just trying to show you it's worth
it and it's practical
so once you actually see a clear vision
of wow
okay what's my niche going to be what am
i going to package what's my online
course going to be what's
what's my positioning what's what's my
difference and then what are the skills
that i need to learn to do this
this could build up year after year
after year and really
eventually give you a freedom-based
business
where you have the autonomy to again you
can do this kind of thing working from
wherever you want
this is the kind of business that you
can do with a laptop and a usb mic in a
webcam
like there's it's an incredibly powerful
business
and it makes me think of like matthew so
matthew
um is uh he's got 34 000 subscribers
weekly videos to help you create music
so it's an education channel right
and matthew is building an email list
and we talk about that in other episodes
of the think marketing podcast
and so he's got like free drum sounds
for the mpc so you actually give him
um you sign up to get these free sounds
because he helps you with the mpc
a music creation tool and then he lets
people know like hey
if you want my seven hours where i go
through
all the functions of the mpc learn what
the buttons do learn how to program them
and he has a 37 dollar course and
matthew's a
nurse is his main main hustle his main
job
and super grateful for him for
especially this year and serving in the
midst of a pandemic
but he's out there serving people and
helping people and he basically recently
told us he's a part of our inner circle
community
he's said that he basically has matched
his monthly income of his
day job with his online income what he's
been doing is taking most of that money
to reinvest in himself and his learning
and scale and gear and equipment
because he's got a vision for what he
wants to do so he's basically do a part
uh a place right now where he can go
part-time or even really full-time if he
stretched it
but he's compounding both things and
it's not just his youtube channel
and adsense and affiliate marketing of
the tech and other things
but he has packaged learned how to
promote
and is profiting from his knowledge
online this is manny
who is a speaker
really preacher itinerant minister
and he actually got crushed at the
beginning
of 2020 because all of his speaking gigs
got cancelled the way he made his living
and paid his mortgage for him and his
wife tia
was he had 24 speaking gigs coming up
this year they
all got cancelled so he
actually went all in and
packaged his knowledge in an online
course called speakeasy
to start help other to help other people
learn how to
particularly teach the bible preach more
powerfully
again a skill he'd built up something
he'd been investing
and been investing in for years my
question is what's the
skill what's something you know and what
can happen is
you sometimes undervalue what you know
and what's already inside of you things
you've just learned in life
like gardening just comes easy for you
and you're like you're awesome at
gardening you keep the aphids away
your neighbors garden all their plants
are dying all of yours are flourishing
like
whatever like there's different skills
that can be very practical that you
could package
promote and profit from and he
completely
replaced his income by moving online
and again rose above recession
specifically in this year
and so uh we have an episode on the
think marketing podcast with manny where
you can learn some powerful
tips from him and again these are all
just other people that are part of
our inner circle program and so his
speakeasy course
59 10 part e-course
and it helps you become a better speaker
particularly for like youth speakers
pastors
conference speakers and people that want
to learn kind of how to teach the bible
things like that
this is nicole from kids ot help she's a
kid's occupational therapist
and same example she's got a new mama
bundle offer
where a lot of things that new mamas
need to learn
it's 333 she's actually created a couple
different online courses
but um that one is a bundle of her
trainings
so what is the skill tell me in the
comments what is a skill you have maybe
maybe you already have an education
based youtube channel or
what is just a skill you you have that
possibly could be packaged into an
online course let me know below and
listen
over the next five years this industry
is growing to as forbes told us to a 325
billion dollar a year industry that's
how much
money is going to be going into
e-learning and people wanting to learn
remote learn on their own terms learn
from home
and as those numbers grow especially
with the lockdown
basically here's what we're talking
about that means by 2025
this is going to be a billion dollar a
day industry
let me say that again that's that's
billion with a b per day
in 2025. i hope you're glad
you're watching this coffee with kennel
right now because
what we're revealing here is that this
is the beginning of a major wave
like this it's just kind of like you're
looking back and being like shoot i
should have invested in amazon stock
you know what i mean like if you would
have invested like 10 grand in amazon
stock back in like 1998
you'd literally i don't know you know be
like ridiculous today
or like you look back you're like man i
should have should have saw that tesla
thing coming come on elon musk
i just want you to see that this is
coming and so
if there's skills to learn which there
are if there's even
positioning for you what's my position
what's my channel about man how do i
build
this whole like potentially knowledge
business empire
well you got time but it's time to go
all in
because you want to position yourself
now to again ride the wave like when the
surf is good
one of my friends jeff morris who lives
in southern california
when the surf is good he goes out and he
rides
he wants to see that opportunity and go
ride the wave
when it's good when there's nothing
there he chills at home and sips coffee
and hangs out with his family
so when you see a wave coming that's the
time to position yourself that's the
time
to level up that's the time to lean in
so let me know if you have any questions
about that and we're going to bring some
guests on
to the coffee with kennel show today
today's episode is brought to you by
talkwiththink.com if you ever have any
questions about our courses
or our monthly coaching program or any
of the things that we do
that help people really in two big areas
our company helps
people number one we help people grow
their youtube channels and really
dominate youtube and figure out how to
crack the code on youtube
how to create the right content rank
your videos get
views 24 7 365 how to really succeed on
youtube
but the second part of our business is
helping people
um build their influence and package
their knowledge in an online course
you know we have over 10 different
income streams in think media we do
brand deals we do affiliate marketing we
do a lot of other things
but in light of what's happening in
culture and in this current wave
and because we have now really perfected
our process
of helping people succeed by packaging
their knowledge in an online course and
youtubers being the best people to do
that like youtube creators and
entrepreneurs using youtube
with an education based channel is
absolutely the best
niche to do so we basically help you
through the whole process and for those
that are part of growth video we booked
down our 10-step process so you know how
that all works
um if you got any questions about that
talk with think.com link in the
description down below
for that um this is coffee with kennel
the show where i bring you on to answer
your questions let me know your biggest
aha moment
let me know what you're sipping on what
you're drinking today and i'm excited to
bring
some people on um my question uh or
quick update if you didn't hear i'm
about to have a baby
and you know we haven't even been
scheduling these things
because babies actually do tomorrow but
we got a friend in town that's here to
help sonia and they've been like
cleaning the garage and like taking
stuff to the goodwill and like
they just got some food they're watching
tv right now so if i got to run out of
here because some water breaks
then then uh it was great hanging out
but um we are literally about to have
our first
son sean bradley cannell at any moment
so that's the life update
and uh my wife sonia is very pregnant 40
weeks pregnant tomorrow
and so we're excited about that and um
with that
i'm excited to uh bring some people on
today
we've got uh keith in the house
what is key it's good at you bro inner
circle fam
and uh tell everybody what you do what
your channel's about
and uh then let me know how i can help
today all right so
first of all good evening good afternoon
good morning wherever you are i'm keith
williams and my channel is better with
improv
and we help you discover what's next
with lessons learned from improv we
we do a lot of different applied improv
for leadership
and for life and business um
first of all let me start with uh i
can't believe you're here with the baby
coming like dude i'm
i'm like it's any you're overdue right
so
uh that's exciting man so
congratulations and uh
i pray and wish for the best for you um
here's why i'm um i've hopped on
something weird happened this week
i'm been diddling with tick-tock
and uh i've been teaching improv and
doing fun tick-tock stuff and i did this
improv rap battle with
token who's some big time rapper and i
went viral
okay and uh 500 000 views in a week
and we gained i don't know we went from
two thousand view
followers to seventeen thousand okay
so from that people have come over we've
given some free improv
classes we've gotten some premiums going
and it's just been a wild week just from
that and and uh so tic toc itself is
just a vessel my original plan was just
go over there direct people over to to
to youtube so here's my question
now that i have this new audience and
many of them are really really
interested in improv itself
do i a try to direct them over to
youtube which is what i've been doing
saying hey i want you to
subscribe over here you're going to get
deeper content
and really from there my sales funnel
starts or
b uh get them right into my sales funnel
from tiktok
directly into um learning more
taking classes signing up for courses
etc
yeah that's a great question and great
job at uh jumping on
again new trends new uh platforms
and um i think keith especially because
you're part of our community
do you have your sales process set up
and the question meaning
you know your opt-in that if somebody
goes to your landing page
and enters their name and email that the
rest
happens through an autoresponder and
through follow-up content
or a free training or any is that built
yet yes yes
so i have it built using squarespace yes
so i have and what do they get there
well
so the for the first premium i have
freemiums that come from youtube that
they get documents how to how to get the
most out of online improv
what's the url uh the url
is better with improv.com
and for the
s for the page uh let's see i think it's
warm-ups let me
see here hold on a second slash warm-ups
hold on warm-up games or
it is yeah slash warm-ups
i think so better within prom.com and
then right on the homepage we have a
link yeah so this is yeah i mean i think
what the the key is
relevancy is key to having this stuff
work online
yeah so looking for a great way to warm
up your meetings
download this free guide this is great
and then people that
specifically want to
this would be of course business leaders
decision makers the people that would be
right for you
um they could go to that page
and then enter their name and email and
then your whole process that could lead
to building your business happens
the key i think is when you look at a
platform like tick tock
is a lot of people all this new audience
that's watching you going viral with
this rapper
recently probably isn't your right
audience and that's okay
because there's something about going
why but then there's something about
also going deep to build our businesses
the the move to make on
tick tock is is what you're is both
in in what you said i mean when i say
both use it to grow your youtube channel
sure use it to send people to this page
great
and the key though is to be really okay
with potentially um
not exciting vanity metrics
so here's my point when we create
something that's funny
clever creative and it goes viral on
tick tock it's
it may be being viewed by people of all
ages that are just if you
not are like right ideal client or
customer which is great but then you do
a next post
that maybe here's the key is like really
polarizing
or almost like meant to not do very well
not that
you want to go as viral as possible but
it's actually really more meant
to just speak directly to the right
person that would benefit from this
chances are your 17 000 new followers
are
not leading that many meetings correct
maybe
one percent of them are so what
messaging does that one percent need to
hear
what tick tock could you create hear me
that is still creative
that hopefully is still entertaining
that still has value
but then leads people to say and if you
want
these three fun and powerful ways to uh
connect with
your you know to build your teams for
team building activities
then you actually give a call to action
to our url it's difficult
for them they'd have to go type it in or
whatever but potentially if
out of your 17 000 followers a hundred
are interested in that maybe 10 want to
go download this and then maybe one
becomes a customer
and your mastery of that
messaging and relevancy and congruency
is how you just keep and not only is how
you keep doing this
but even in this training we talked
about 2.7 sales a day
eventually once your proven sales
process and your buy button all that
stuff is built
you can have fun on social media all day
long by just thinking new and creative
ways
to sort of send the right people or
attract the right people
to a particular form of messaging and
alternatively what might be better than
sending them to this page is exactly
what you're doing
is attracting them to your youtube
channel but one of the biggest mistakes
we can make as online entrepreneurs
is actually truly trying to reach
everybody and i'm guilty of this i just
i
we all want the big numbers like okay
what will get the most clicks what will
get the most likes
what will get the most comments it's not
a very good question to ask the better
question
if you want to do this full-time is what
will get the most customers
right who is my ideal client what will
attract my ideal client
what can i do to go wide to if you will
serve
and entertain and help a lot of people
but then how can i narrow that down with
really relevancy in my messaging
and i would then leverage tick tock and
as we land the plane i think what's
exciting is that this then opens the
window to all kinds of platforms because
once you sort of get your knowledge
business dialed in
as you know we can go on linkedin a new
platform like you're doing a new
platform like tick tock or instagram
reals comes out
and we start experimenting with a new
tool or a new platform on social media
but it's all with a purpose why
because we've built our online business
first and we're dialing in
our online business as well is that
making sense i mean what do you think
with that
uh okay so you said a lot let me let me
give you some some great news with that
first of all
the trainings that i learned here with
you with
um with this particular program with the
inner circle with vr all that stuff
is is applicable over there so a sifting
through all of the
all of the thousands of general people
who came over for some
some hip-hop thing who's who wants to
learn improv
who's who's my audience and again like
you said you're going to get tens
not thousands right you're going to get
less than 100 people we've already
just by going live uh and said hey who
you might take a free uh improper acting
class i had a full class
people came in they now definitely want
to take the course so so yes number two
the sales pages
they're different sales pages based on
where they come from so
depends on the youtube video what we're
teaching what what the freemium is
so tick tock has three tick tock has
direct links
to websites to youtube too
so i don't have they don't have to
manually do anything i can certainly
send them to a link tree
or send them to my sales page depending
on what we're doing
number four is um is that yes
the viral video itself got the attention
now that i have your attention
we did some follow-ups we did we said
okay how do i just straight
do talking head teaching improv we
didn't do that what we did was we said
okay we're gonna teach it
through this hip-hop so we now so we did
the
the improv commandments using the
tendulk commandments from hamilton so we
did improv hamilton style with
rap taught it did a four-part series
and then did another uh rap challenge
after it and all of a sudden
the audience grew and people like man i
love improv and um
if you love improv you're gonna follow
back and then they become part of my
community
and so again we send them that way what
i what i want to make sure
um what i was talking to you about here
is you know
again because i'm still trying to grow
youtube i'm so distracted by this tick
tock it's like do i try to get everybody
over and you answer that by saying yes
but i also need to get them into an
appropriate sales funnel based on the
appropriate
um thing that i'm offering and there of
course are multiple sales
pages and funnels for that i don't know
if that made sense backward to you
oh i love it you got it keith and i
appreciate you so much and i'm super
grateful that you've been a part of our
various communities
uh and um it's amazing to see your
success man all the different doors of
opportunity opening and
you crushing it on multiple platforms
this stuff works man that's why i'm
dude i'm telling you what you're doing
is amazing and uh
and heather and grow with video live
like i said a huge success
very proud of it um under the
circumstances you guys hit like a grand
slam home run
in my opinion so congratulations great
job on that
well thanks keith hey i appreciate you
so much and thanks for coming on coffee
with kennel
thanks bro cheers all right friends
coffee with kennel i hope you're rising
and grinding hit the like button if
you've been getting some insights
out of this uh video so far coming up
next on the show
we've got john in just a second um
but uh i hope that you're maybe taking
some notes and thinking about how does
this apply to your business and your
brand you might have a lot of different
ideas spinning around
in your mind you might have a lot of
different ideas happening
but at the end of
the day congruency relevance
alignment with your audience one of the
biggest mistakes people are making on
social media is they're only
trying to go viral they're only trying
to potentially
reach a lot of people and in social
media step one
is you do got to get attention but then
step two is you want to make sure you're
attracting
the right people and you want to
potentially be
polarizing to other people so what i
mean is
maybe a lot of people watch your youtube
channel but they're not one of your 1000
super fans
you want to create a journey for people
to be on
that there's almost like a gateway where
people go i don't want to walk through
that but the person who does
is the ideal person that you can help
you can serve with your content and
eventually
your online course or your coaching or
whatever it is and
so uh man it's cool to see what keith is
doing and we've got
uh john on the show john how's it going
um tell me a little bit about your
business your brand and what you're up
to
all right so uh first off thanks
appreciate you having me on
and um congrats on baby sean because
that's awesome and exciting
um so i right now i do gaming
so hence the pc it's a clash of clans
and bra stars i actually started it
because my dad's 74 he plays the game he
needed some videos
so i kind of helped him out and it kind
of grew and i had a little following but
i can't
i'm i have three kids so i'm investing
time
away and i need to monetize so i kind of
pivoted
with growth video live and it gave me a
lot of insight i'm a graphic design
and marketer by trade and so i figured
why not do design for life uh with john
feldhaus and that's my name
so uh can i get my name out there i have
feldhouse.net and then i'm just going to
kind of
build a brand from there i have for my
first video i kind of want to do
um marketing and design
and i wanted to put some courses
together so what i was kind of thinking
based on your feedback from girl with
video is have
a couple video series and then lump them
together and then i can actually do like
a course
more detailed with that um
and then that would be kind of like
design wise because i think
that's going to be the quicker route so
i kind of wanted to see what your
thought process was do i go higher value
or do i go quicker to
get executed because i know i could
knock those design videos out really
quick versus
a marketing because marketing is so all
over the place
so my that's kind of my general question
to you
yeah i love it john and thanks so much
for being a part of uh growth video
live and um yeah what i would say
not just to encourage you but everybody
watching is
we have a phrase in our brand that you
heard
what's the shortest path to revenue and
part of
something to think about with the
shortest path is um
you know if you were to want to build a
whole
car you could sell the car for a lot of
money potentially
but you'd have to build a whole car
alternatively
if you just sold some armor all dash
cleaner
you might be able to get that product to
market a lot faster because you're not
actually building a car you're just
building one little piece
it comes with a microfiber cloth spray
the armor all on
come on any car fanatics like me you
would do the you'd have the leather
and the armor all you'd have the tire
cleaner if you detail your own car
all these different car products so like
what's a smaller product that you could
get to market faster
and when it comes to online courses we
think about that as a mini offer
aka a tiny offer aka
a baby offer and um
it's one thing if you were to say i have
created
the photoshop academy it is 400
hours long by the time you get to the
end of it you'll be able to
3d render you know it's not even really
photoshop but you'll be able to
literally do everything or like the
beginner's
jump start to achieving this result
with say something like photoshop and it
could be anything
and you start thinking about a couple
things you want to get dialed in
is exactly like who is your target
audience the way to stand out in this
thing
is not to just create potentially a
general core uh
online course but to really create it
for a specific group of people
like helping teachers learn photoshop
because teachers now need to do their
own
graphic design for all the virtual or
e-learning that's actually finding like
a niche within a niche it's finding a
niche and you're a marketer so you know
what i'm talking about
so uh so it's something like that it's
creating something small that you could
create fast market fast and get sales
going
quicker and even generate customers
quicker um
that then you could then bolt on the
next step you could essentially use
your armor all car cleaning product
business
to maybe even fund how hard it would be
to create a manufacturing plant to build
real cars
so it's it's even a cool way that the
new economy is created for us as online
entrepreneurs
to actually bootstrap and stack and fund
multiple different projects does that
make sense you create a smaller offer
you get some stuff going
maybe eventually you get some help or
you buy yourself some time or you buy
yourself some leverage
so you could actually create something
that's at a higher level and
you also have a built-in client base and
potentially the ability to get some
passive
income and passive customers being
generated because it's going gonna be
easier to sell a product for seven
dollars or twenty seven dollars or forty
seven dollars
and then eventually you say hey by the
way my new thing's out
my my 500 record my thousand dollar
full-on academy
my my five-day workshop where you come
and we sit down
like whatever you want to do next you
sort of are like building out the
customer journey as you go these are
hardware and one lessons that i learned
the first course i ever created was an
academy
and it stressed me the heck out man it
was like it was super long
i was overwhelmed my head was like
spaghetti trying to like think about and
then you know
and and things went good but just
learning from what i learned creating
video ranking academy which is amazing
and
it's now gone through multiple
iterations we just recently overhauled
the whole thing
looking back i would have created a tiny
offer
first that was also if you will lower
ticket more affordable
and they talk about in in business in
general that it's something like
a thousand times easier to sell
something else to an existing customer
than it is to even create a customer and
in marketing
cost per conversion cost per
customer can be astronomical that
becomes kind of the barrier to entry
it's like once you are a customer i've
been buying all this running clothes
workout clothes lately
as i was going through 75 hard and i'm
noticing how much
retargeting these brands are doing like
as soon as i hit their website
or i make a purchase dude i'm they're
hitting me everywhere they're in my
instagram feed facebook and i'm like wow
the reason these products cost what they
cost is because they are built
into their whole sales process the
marketing margin
to probably spend to sell me these
designer running shorts
for like 70 they're probably spending 35
dollars to try to get me to become a
customer at first
and they're doing it because they're
berating anyways you get kind of the
idea so
as we land the plane that's kind of is
what i would think is i would think
how do you start with the shortest path
to revenue
um and then give yourself some leverage
and some
cash cash is king cash flow is king
cash's oxygen to your business and then
you're reinvesting that cash to scale up
build the next thing get your youtube
channel growing more does that make
sense
absolutely i mean that's exactly what i
mean
i didn't want to just jump because i
have all these awesome ideas
but as you know uh you know a bird in
the hand is worth two in the bush so
it's like i'd rather have something
going in generating
but uh sorry my dog just wanted to say
hello he's uh who's that
super needy this is gus he's
he lost his sister recently so he's just
been super whiny and so i didn't want
him to get all in the way but i
apologize for that diversion
no i'm glad gus came on the show we uh
we had two chihuahuas we did lose one
lately although we lost rosie sophie
didn't seem to care too much she's
pretty independent
i think she was grateful that she was
relieved of
her annoying sister uh but we have
missed her dearly but uh i'm sorry to
hear that
uh no it's all good but congrats on the
baby thank you so much for taking the
time i
i want to have you get to other people
so thank you so much
for sure john i appreciate you thank you
and take care gus we'll see you
um all right we're gonna have cat on in
just a second and then we got techno dad
coming up but
um what is your shortest
path to revenue hey tell me what you
think it is in the comments or the live
chat
uh click like if you've been getting
value out of this training
so far and remember today's episode is
brought to you by talk with think if you
have been a part of our um you know
business our channel for a while
uh whether you're watching on facebook
or or
on youtube and you are kind of wondering
how we could help you here at the think
company
talk with think.com and we can do a
15-minute discovery call that's for you
if you're serious it's not a coaching
call it is to learn a little bit more
about
our accelerators we have various
programs that can help you reach your
goals faster of course we're always here
to serve you with the think marketing
podcast with the think media channel
with the free content that we are
sharing just like this to help you reach
your goals but we have some ways to get
there faster like if you want all the
steps and all the right order
then um you can learn more about some of
the things that we have at talk with
think dot com we've got
cat on cat how's it going what is your
uh
what are what are you up to what's kind
of your business or your brand and where
are you joining us from today
i am on the west coast of canada
vancouver island
in bc um and i
yeah i do custom cards and gifts awesome
all kinds of things in that and i think
my fastest way to making money on that
is to do a digital version of what i
design
rather than individual cards which take
time to make
and that's fun but it's also fun to
teach it so i actually had an
affiliate question yep um affiliate
links i
did take i did sign up with the amazon
and i'm curious as to how it exactly the
legal side of it
there seem to be a lot of rules with
what you should post when you post their
links and whether it qualifies you to
actually make any money off it
like i had a sale through my link but it
didn't qualify i'm not quite sure why
or is there a simplified version of
the legality so that we know what we
have to post to include
to make the link valid yeah really good
question so when it comes to the amazon
associates program in particular and
affiliate marketing in particular here's
kind of a list of things
to know as it as it pertains to
compliance
and of affiliate marketing
first is you do want to be familiar with
the ftc the federal trade center
guidelines you're based in canada which
by the way my wife sonia and i
uh grew up in kind of the seattle area
and we went to vancouver island went uh
once on like a date we went up rode the
ferry over
absolutely love it there and um and
you're based in canada but
you probably have viewers in canada
internationally and then also
in the u.s and youtube's the u.s company
and so no matter where you're watching
this
in the world um you do want to be
thinking about
the u.s regulations of something like
affiliate marketing
and so one of those is disclosures
and what we would typically do is
is have a a disclosure a disclaimer in
the youtube description
above the affiliate links and so in most
think media or think marketing videos on
youtube
it'll say this video is not sponsored
to let people know that it's not
sponsored um links
below assume links below are affiliate
links which means
if you click them we earn a small
commission
and so we have that disclaimer usually
there and then usually another one lower
that's even more detailed
so one of the things the ftc expects is
that the disc
the disclaimer is actually above it's
not like buried at the bottom of your
website
you know in some corner but it's
actually ahead of
uh what people um uh can see it if
they're gonna click those links
secondly it actually is best to verbally
disclose in the video if a link is an
affiliate link
and so that is another thing now
amazon's probably not going to actually
be measuring those things i don't get
exactly to your question but those are
some of the best practices
and uh youtube also gives you a box you
can check that says includes paid
promotion
some people think do i need to check
that well you don't you're not actually
getting paid to promote anything you may
earn a commission if somebody clicks the
link
uh but but you should be fine there and
then across the board
depending on the website depending on it
could be a blog
other websites like facebook like
different social media platforms might
have different regulations about
affiliate marketing
and what can happen is sometimes
especially when the channel
is newer sometimes it runs into issues
like uh we have we're maybe so
established and we just have a good
reputation with youtube and i don't even
mean like anyone knows us i mean like
just their bots they're they're like
okay
think media has not had copyright
strikes really they're you know
they're they're a healthy channel we
maybe just kind of get away with things
that maybe sometimes new channels are
like i don't know like there's issues
because youtube's bots and assume this
about other social media platforms if a
channel is brand new
sometimes what they don't want they
don't want black hat marketers
which simply means people with like kind
of a scammy or spammy agenda just create
a new channel
stuff links try to like rank videos try
to siphon dollars out of
so they like you just kind of want to
think about compliance and usually if
you've got
a channel like crafting and custom cards
and you're creating good valuable
content
you also should be fine in regards to
those types of things now
where amazon gives you that open window
of time for those that want to sign up
for the amazon associates program right
you sign up and a lot of times you get
approved quickly these
days but they say you have to make a
certain number of qualified sales
within a certain window of time and
it's kind of hard to say what those
qualified sales are for some
sometimes maybe what they try to do is
someone clicks
uh you click your own links to buy
things maybe you don't even mean to or
maybe somebody
that is on your ip address or similar ip
address
and amazon's paying attention to uh hey
those sales
do not qualify the other thing is that
it is very frustrating but when you are
just starting out
it seems like you will see okay i made
four sales i made one sale i made five
sales
and amazon seems to this is just kind of
my opinion so i'm kind of going from
conjecture here
if you don't hit critical mass of sales
maybe from a diverse source of buyers
meaning more than just a handful then
they don't start
crediting you yet like if you only make
a couple sales
they're like it's not enough to hit
qualification yet we have so many people
that are um making sales like in our
video ragged academy program
and kind of running into this i see
there's like six sales but they say
they're not qualified
and um of course amazon's always
updating their terms of service and
whatnot
and they can say what a qualified sale
is what that could also be
is sometimes you might make a sale that
actually is not
an it doesn't relate to any earning any
money with affiliate marketing
like it could be someone clicks your
link purchases
an amazon prime movie rental for 4.99
and it's a sale but it's actually not
something that you
earn anything from so that's just
another example there's a couple things
happening in the middle there so my
final advice
is to establish your channel
think about your disclo your disclaimers
you know always be above board
what we call white hat online marketing
which just means like ethical
transparent versus black hat and uh
you and then just put out good content
but really
grow your influence first influence
comes first income comes second
and in our video racket academy program
we talk about hitting around
making it a goal to have around 200 to
300 views of video
and to be making videos that directly
lead to sales
so that you're not just making like a
sale here or there but you actually hit
a tipping point
of having some momentum on the channel
and having videos that lead to sales
meaning
videos that like if you reviewed the
best scissors for
uh you know creating crafts and that
actually had some serious traffic and
interest around it
so that video kind of like jennifer
from the sewing report in our community
she
did a review of one of the best budget
sewing machines
that video has like 80 000 views and a
lot of people are looking for it a lot
of people want to know the budget
machine they find that at this brother
machine she teaches how to use it
and she's selling like a lot of sewing
machines she hit a tipping point
of generating qualified sales and there
is some sort of a tipping point that
kind of
kicks your account over to amazon's like
okay you're good and from there you just
scale up does that make sense any
questions about that no no it does that
makes perfect sense the affiliate links
i was just a little bit dubious and i
only put one
on like two different videos and i kind
of had a sale but i was like looking at
my stats and
how did it not qualify i just thought
i'd done it wrong put the wrong thing
down
and i didn't want to continue to do that
i haven't had a video on for a few weeks
i moved house and then did this massive
conference
i was really busy with that um it was
epic by the way guys
um and i just haven't had a chance so i
feel guilty now i haven't posted a video
for three weeks i'm gonna start vra next
week
um and so i think i just keep taking
those steps and i'll add the link slowly
and little by little
build it up i think awesome awesome so
yeah i think uh exactly what you just
said and i'm grateful you're part of
growth video live
and that is exactly what can happen
though is time off
away from momentum i want to see you
know multiple videos coming out
with multiple affiliate links in them
and encourage you you are absolutely
on the right track critical mass is
almost like thinking
hitting a tipping point critical mass is
like releasing five videos in a row
all that are related to affiliate
marketing to like really get the
snowball going you know what i mean like
let's
let's like do like a mini launch and and
maybe
a couple of those videos are tutorials
and helpful but a couple of them are
your favorite
crafting custom cards kind of products
so you just come out
strong to quote unquote launch
your affiliate income business does that
make sense it makes sense i use a really
flashy cutting machine and
a lot of people looking for comparisons
so that's that's given me some
really good ideas thanks for your
congrats on the baby we can't wait to
see pictures
oh thank you so much kat hey i
appreciate you and thanks so much for
coming on
thank you bye coffee with cannell my
friends
the show where we are helping you build
your influence your income
with online video and taking your
influence and your knowledge and packing
packaging that
in an online course package it promote
it and profit from what you know
we've got chana the techno dad on the
show a dj
yes you can catch his dj sets on his
channel a dj by trade
yes you can hire him to dj your next
event and also
a home theater expert crushing it
china what's happening in your business
lately dog i mean you got like
money flowing in from multiple streams
um
what's been working for you lately um
you know what um oddly enough not
editing videos
that's that's been working so like this
i sit down
start talking about stuff um and like
we're just recording yeah yeah live
stream
and then you talk about some gear and
some home theater stuff or yeah
yeah mostly about like tvs because you
know these they're changing all these
hdmi
specs and all this kind of stuff and
there's new information all the time and
you know i was like well let's see it
could take me 15 minutes to record the
video
three hours to edit it and then you know
make a thumbnail and all that kind of
stuff so
like that one that one that yeah so that
was a live stream
um i did what tuesday and it's got 3 700
views and i would just
when i see the you know um the people
watching counter
i would just reiterate what the topic is
and just kind of go back to it um and
you had a stream yard or something
yeah i was using stream yard just to
just to you know bring everybody's
you know uh comments or questions and
then i would just go through q a
and i would just try to put up pretty
much every comment if it was
you know clean um and then
the video i did last week is already is
almost at ten thousand views uh that
future-proof one
yeah this one right here that's another
live stream yeah c-string this one's
9600 yeah yeah and so i'm like
i'm like man i just i don't need to edit
videos if it's a
topic that i know a lot about so um so
that's been working out pretty well
um i think you know maybe i'll do one of
those
with an edited video so two videos a
week
um and just kind of kind of keep the
content coming out there but um
you know i'm actually starting my first
uh
um what is a digital product nice
so um i know john was on here earlier
and he was talking about
he had all these great ideas and you
know i had all this stuff
you know i have a website already i have
a a press kit already
haven't touched those in like a year
okay and
it's just because there's all this other
stuff going on but recently
i got connected with this company uh for
an affiliate program and they are
allowing me
their big big time distributor and and
you know retailer um so they're allowing
me four thousand dollars worth of
gear to review per month so i'm like oh
i can get two tvs per month to review
for the channel
so that's kind of like what i've been
doing life is hard by the way just
just just shed a tear for uh shauna in
the uh comments if you're
if you're just mourning the fact that he
has to struggle through
4 000 of gear hey by the way
because he punched fear in the face and
he built his influence in a niche that
he's passionate about
you know what i mean like how epic i
mean
let's just say now i've been practicing
my 30-second um
you know pitch so i'll let you guys know
what's happening right i'm the highest
paid wedding dj
in my town along with that i also have
10 to 15 music students
i worked two nights graveyard at a hotel
type place
and my weekly tuesday night was the best
tuesday night
in my town for about five years so
along with all of that i started a
youtube channel from scratch and now
i've got what 530 some videos
13 million views and 82 000 plus
subscribers
so if you're telling me or telling
yourself you don't have time
you're wrong i made time and with all
those other four things happening
i built up this this channel and you
know every time i see an email saying
yo do you want to be on coffee with
kennel do i want to talk to the guy
directly who
like had a big uh impact on changing my
life
yes yes let me i was actually about to
work out and i saw this happening i'm
like oh
hey uh i'm gonna go downstairs you know
tell my wife she's like what are you
doing now because she
wants me to do the workout you know i'm
trying to avoid it but
anyway that's a different story so um
so anyway i you know i review tvs i
review home
home audio equipment home entertainment
stuff and
i haven't actually reviewed any tvs um
you know until
you know i didn't get one in until a
couple months ago because i figured
i need to learn how to calibrate the tvs
because my
opinions about an uncalibrated tv would
just kind of be like it wouldn't have
any frame of reference
right so i spent two grand on the
calibration tools uh contacted the
calibration company
their software is three thousand dollars
a year um
they decided to give me that for free on
a reviewer program
so cool um the other cool part was
the guy was on the phone with me for i
think about four
two hour sessions and i would sit there
and it was team viewers so he can see
what's happening on my computer screen
and i would make all the adjustments on
the tv literally taught me
through teamviewer how to calibrate the
tvs manually
and um so i've got all these tvs coming
in
i can calibrate the tvs and when you
manually do these
honestly some of these are like i'm
changing five or six settings and
there's
the like graphs on the um you know
pre-calibration are all over the place
and then
after they're all like in a row you know
all the colors little dots are in the
squares so everything's accurate
and then my friend was like so if i take
those settings can i plug them in to my
tv and i'm like yeah they'd be around
the same thing so you know normally cost
like 300 to 600 dollars to have a
professional calibrator come to your
home
and you know with covet 19 and all this
other stuff probably not the best thing
so
well i have a website and i have um
this pdf or you know well it's a
photoshop situation i make it to a pdf
of my press kit so i have all my
branding
set up so now i've repurposed
my uh press kit into a settings packet
for all these tvs and i'll give you
settings for
dark room lightroom and game mode no
professional calibrator
calibrates game mode so it's
differentiating and i'm selling these
things for fifty dollars a piece
and i put i put my pitch in the review
video
of that specific tv and i use my website
to
do the sales so all i need are two
thousand sales
a year at fifty dollars to make that
hundred thousand
along with all the other things that i'm
doing boom mic drop moment did y'all
hear that and what a creative way
to sell a digital product that
serves people and saves people massive
money
because it's software's super expensive
hiring a calibrator all this stuff can
be super expensive
and serving people getting that what the
word is
arbitrage finding that middle uh
ground where it's a great investment to
have your tv set up right and to get the
details for it specifically and
at fifty dollars two thousand sales that
is a six
figure year business um and on top of
that you still love djing you still got
youtube ads you got brands you could do
other things
and so what's crazy is i know a lot of
us would love to maybe just hit our
target of
40k a year um hit a six figure a year
business
but you can scale this in like whatever
your ambitions are this can turn into
multiple six figures this could
really grow and um that's really
inspiring
yeah um and i'm reusing the stuff that i
bought like i paid a graphics guy to
make my press kit
haven't used it in a year you know
website i'm still paying for it haven't
used haven't
you know and the website was from you
know your guys you know saying you
should have a website where you
transcribe the you know video so you
have a text thing and
embed the video and it'll come up on
search and oddly enough
my most frequently visited um
website page is like how to set up hdr
for an xbox
one x on an lg and when i google that my
my article is number one and my video is
number one so
like when you google search that so like
having that is great just
you know there's just so much only so
much time i can dedicate to
you know creating those blog posts and
moving things over um especially with
all the other jobs
and other stuff i have to do um i was
thinking about hiring somebody but i was
like eh
and i just kind of forgot about it but
now and like you know it was just a
wordpress site and i already have
woocommerce
i just had to activate it so i've got
now like you know the website name
shop and my two tests um are up there
and you know as the channel continues to
grow over 100 000 subscribers
i'll have multiple tvs more tvs coming
in every year
like this is something that can snowball
i think into at least like
you know easily like 200 300 000 a year
just on that depending you know if
things continue the way they're going
so well that's it bro well i appreciate
you coming on the show and so grateful i
mean
you've been a part of video ranking
academy for a while like years
three years now i've four years doing
youtube three years in video ranking
academy and
uh yeah man i know um i'm i'm branching
off into uh
twitch getting subscribers on twitch for
my dj streams
and uh you know my friend i
she's an old school dj in vegas has
multiple or had multiple you know vegas
residencies
and i know from back in college and i
was like oh you should get on twitch you
should
try stream elements three months later
she's got like 500 subscribers
so she's making like 2 000 a month djing
three nights a week
granted it's for like six hours a night
you know these are long
long sessions um but she's having a
blast
and she's so surprised and she's only
been doing it for three months so
you know there's a lot of uh you know
when when you go
all in or when you start having these
ideas like hey let me just try this if
you
do something and try it just to try it
and see how it is
without thinking about how much money
you're gonna make like the reward
on that risk you're taking you know can
can be huge
i love it man well hey i appreciate you
and uh thanks so much
for uh coming on the show go do that
workout now man
yeah yeah yeah and hey congratulations
on uh you know
um junior baby coming soon i know
any moment we keep talking uh we keep
joking around where we go man it'd be
nice if he came during the day and then
and then as we're like we're kind of
getting tired at night i go you think
you're going to the hospital babe she's
like i don't want to i want to sleep
you know but hopefully it comes at 10
a.m tomorrow
yeah come on our timetable sean bradley
we'd appreciate that right
appreciate you man thank you so much for
coming on no problem talk to you later
peace
cheers bro all right we are going to
have uh
marcus on in just a second and uh we'll
be landing
the plane michelle said this is so
inspiring wow having the business
mindset is everything
i love that michelle and that's the
power of
coffee with cannell where we're here to
help you build that
business mindset get your grindr on your
hustle right your income flow and your
influence
growing and so um really cool
uh story there and uh
your battle station is epic rachel says
uh yeah techno dad's got the the led
lights behind
the power of live streaming and my
friends you got to build your battle
station
meaning you got just like right now i'm
live streaming i'm using stream yard and
i'm
live streaming to um multiple
different places right we're over on
facebook we're on youtube
and if you ever kind of want to know the
tools we use
uh think media tools dot
go to thinkmediatools.com because we
talk about
whether it's software whether it's video
editing whether it's where we get our
music
think media tools dot com including
our live stream gear because the power
of building a battle station
is being able to create content like the
coffee with kennel show
so inspiring to see that techno dad is
not just doing pre-recorded videos
but he's tapping into the power of live
streaming it's not either or it's both
and we do pre-recorded
and edited content we do live content by
the way
we record online courses in this battle
station
i do meetings with my team now
at that stage with this battle station i
meet with brands
at this battle station when you switch
from
dabbling to dominating you want to have
the tools for the trade
it's okay to start with whatever you
have and it really is never about your
resources it's about your
resourcefulness
but at some point you got to be thinking
about man
what gear do i need to do this at a
world-class level
and that's about building your battle
station so i hope you're subscribed
to think media i can't even wait for the
next couple weeks and months we are
going to go so deep
in lighting webcams usb
mics software live streaming zoom tips
building battle stations so that we can
create content
at a world-class level and
if you want to learn about the tools we
use check out all of our tools at
think media tools dot
com we have another session coming on
but i'm wondering if we could get this
video to a hundred likes
on youtube smash the like button if you
haven't and maybe share this stream for
somebody else
that's trying to figure out how to
um build their extra income streams
take their knowledge or their hobby or
their passion online and start creating
content around it
and uh let me know uh hit smash that
like button
share the stream if you've been getting
value today on this coffee with cannell
episode the day before
my wife's due date officially i heard
that it's actually tomorrow i've been
saying it wrong
and people have been like oh sometimes
that first one comes a little bit late
so maybe it's this weekend
maybe it's tonight maybe it's next week
i'm excited
very soon i will be going into dad mode
and uh
i'm going to uh i'm excited for that
season well hey
we got marcus on the show marcus my man
remind people what it is that you do and
where you're streaming from and let me
know how i can help
yeah absolutely i'm based in basel
switzerland
and my main channel is a communication
tips from
a comedian and i just started also a
second channel last week about um
about financial independence which is
actually something that you and i talked
about about a month ago on the stream so
i
i took the decision to make a little
pause on my main channel and go for the
for the personal finance stuff so i've
been really inspired
to get started with with affiliate
marketing
and i have a question about the
different styles of using affiliate
links
so one style is very simple like you
know buy the canon m50
amazon link then there's a style that
like vanessa lao uses where it says
here's my favorite camera and there's an
amazon link but she doesn't tell you
which camera is you have to click the
link to find out
and then there's a style that that you
use which is like kit dot co
and then the site that you just
mentioned with all the tools so i'm
wondering which of these
different styles would you would you
recommend what are the pros and cons of
doing like vanessa's method
i imagine that that the advantage of
that is that
you get the cookie on you get the amazon
cookie just for finding out which camera
it is
so i would appreciate a little bit of um
thoughts as i'm just getting started
with them
with affiliate marketing in the next
couple of months
yeah that's a great question and i like
that you just detailed i mean you just
added value to our community
um by breaking that down i i don't
know or i'll give my opinion on if
there's i don't think
any of those methods is wrong for for
one i think it'd be interesting in
experimenting
i would say that um i think at think
media
we have definitely kind of tapped into
doing affiliate marketing at a pretty
world-class level
i mean just just to look at and i
haven't looked at it recently we've been
doing
a um we are
at uh just this month at something like
117
000 clicks um and have earned
14 000 uh in profit just this month
pretty decent so let's see last month
um we did something like thirty four
thousand
uh 189 dollars and
we can also see of course a lot of that
has to do with camera photography
musical instruments you can see how it
breaks down and this is the back end
um you know friends we don't only just
have the clicks here but the amount of
ordered items
uh the conversion rate 5.61
that i think is a is a big key in answer
to your question
because the conversion rate is not
necessarily
it has to do maybe with how valuable the
video is and thinking through the entire
customer journey in affiliate marketing
if that makes sense
because um i think what's happened at
think media
a couple summarized principles is i
think part of it's trust
again affiliate marketing for us is not
just like a cash grab
it's understanding how to monetize
truly valuable information to say hey
here's a comparison of two things and
this is really why we think this is the
better option
choice is yours but people have built
trust with us over the years and have
said man
when it's exactly that's the goal it's
exactly
as sean described or no omar subscribed
or nolan
described and i feel like i've invested
my money in something that's good
and of course affiliate marketing
doesn't make the product cost anymore
so it's such a great way to earn money
as a creator but to maybe answer your
your question more specifically
we've bolted on um i think the think
media tools page
that we just give an example that's
something eventually everybody should do
because eventually as an online
entrepreneur you should have
what tools you use on your website like
think about it right eventually
you're going to probably pick a place
where you're going to be building your
email list eventually you're going to
pick
i mean for us it's crazy how many
different i mean we have
at this stage in business slack and
monday.com and we use epidemic music and
we use musicbed and
we use kajabi and we also use thinkific
and
we also use a text message service i
forget what it's called
and we also use vid iq and so eventually
there's just so many different tools
um by summarizing where those all are
you can share it quickly like i just did
and if people want an example go to fake
media tools
it's an example of exactly what you said
in regards these of course are our
affiliate links
and it's taken i want to encourage you
it's taken years
right to to build this all up um and
and so start simple in regards to
vanessa's method yes maybe you get the
click but my guess is
a couple things i don't think she takes
like amazon affiliate marketing anywhere
near as serious as we do
because she's built such a profitable
coaching and even course business
helping people with instagram and
building businesses
um and most i haven't met anybody that
is anywhere near our results in
affiliate marketing so i do think if i
was to lean
not just because it's kind of our
process if you look at our process of
doing it
it's sort of a linear flow of
super valuable search based video
answering a question and giving what we
believe to be the most
ethical solid helpful answer
and then clearly letting people find
that answer in the description so things
like
verbal call to actions to let people
know and so there are links in the
description
to these products maybe even knowing
ahead of time before you press record
and right now webcams are kind of sold
out
and kind of hard to find and so i've
actually linked a couple
different resources in the description
down below so you can check
b h photo amazon and
ebay which may be the only place that
you can get this webcam right now
that is just very clear instructions to
the viewer
to be able to now go search that out
click those links
and if they were to click amazon
ba b h and ebay that cookie would be on
all three sites
in in regards to uh or on that computer
for all three sites
in regards to whatever purchases they
make for whatever the cookie time frame
is
so i'm not sure if i answer your
question good but uh what are your
thoughts
on that end
but the idea of of building your
that side of your own i think that is
probably a good
good idea also to show you to show your
viewers that you are serious that that
you do you know
evaluate all these different products
and i i guess that would
it's that would give a good impression
to somebody that oh
he doesn't only push this one product
but he actually has
intelligent views about all these
different things so i i'm i'm
inspired to put together that list and i
think it doesn't have to be complicated
i think i could just put it on my
wordpress site it could just be a page
here are the tools that i use
with affiliate things right 100 and then
it becomes both
you can have even that link in your
description
all the time to just people could maybe
stumble on it
um you could have the specific video
with a specific call to action like
you're doing here
um talking about maybe m50 versus canon
the camcorder so you have the m50 link
or a zoom affiliate link does zoom have
an affiliate program
to have it but i think they quit it
during the the current situation yeah
that makes sense
that's something that we haven't really
promoted so um you know whatever it is
whether it could be stream yard or
something
else you talk about but then the power
of having those clear urls or something
clear you could share on a live stream
is exactly thinkmediatools.com
it also gives you the chance to maybe go
live answer q a or even share on social
like you could send a tweet out
that that website stands alone so at the
end of the day
i love the question because you brought
up a couple different strategies
and that is what we should all kind of
be developing at some point we might
find our secret sauce the best strategy
for us
but my kind of summary answer is do all
of them i mean it
or or do the best one for the context of
the
cr of the content you're creating you
know what i mean you never
as this is a great tip too you usually
in any one video
you only want one call to action though
and that's kind of a good online
marketing like if you tell people to go
four places they're gonna go nowhere
because like i can't how can i go in
four directions is it north south east
or west
so when thinking about what strategy
you're going to use
in regards to a call to action to an
affiliate link or whatever
i would encourage always research before
you press record
and plan your video before you press
record to think through the whole
process
as we get better in creating our videos
it's actually thinking through the whole
thing of
of how does this all align how is this
all congruent
so that the viewer it's one of those
things where once you're done recording
you're editing or the video is coming
out you're like shoot i should have said
i've done that a million times
wait a minute like i could have been a
lot how did it make that very easy for
the viewer
and i'm sure that everybody watching
this can maybe relate where you look
back and you're like
shoot i i what if i would have given a
call to action one of the things that i
find so fascinating is uh
is i remember i used to i was like
flipping watches
and i looked at like these nixon watches
like a watch like this
and uh i would see a watch like this
video right here
where this person just shows off this
watch
and uh okay it looks like they might
have an affiliate link
nope they don't it's not it's not an
affiliate link to ebay and it doesn't
link to anything
and so this particular video by just
kind of reviewing a watch
as 86 000 views and potentially no
affiliate link in the description
so one there's the idea of
the chance that you always could put an
affiliate link in the description
um and that could be at least an
opportunity for some
but the second level is if you don't
give an actual call to action
then chances are no one's gonna find
that link like a very small percentage
and once the video is out and once it
has 81 656 views
you might look back on an old video and
be like dang i could be having some
passive income right now
but hopefully that becomes a lesson and
even watching this coffee with kennel we
think through
to be like man on that next one i just
want to make sure that
my my messaging my call to actions the
things i include in the video the verbal
call to actions i give the description
i want to make that i want to remove
friction as best as possible
and just make sure i'm clear and helpful
and i serve the viewer
and i let them know about a summary of
show notes and links in the description
or whatever
because if you don't give that verbal
call to action then chances are you're
not going to ever make
any affiliate sales or you're going to
make very few so that's just kind of a
practical tip for everybody
on uh coffee with cannell today marcus
was that helpful
yeah absolutely very powerful i got some
good ideas from them thank you very much
i appreciate that
awesome and well hey i appreciate you
and thanks so much for coming on coffee
with kennel
thank you cheers all right coffee with
kennel thank you
for uh smashing that like button man we
only got to 93 likes while i was live
can we hit a hundred can we throw some
champagne coffee in the air and uh and
see if we could reach all the way to a
hundred
and let me know what um you're gonna do
next
you know we're action takers here at the
think media company
and um uh what action item
after today is it to start exploring how
you could create an online course
um is it uh making your next video is it
getting better at affiliate marketing
and realizing shoot
and i had some videos where i talked
about some stuff and i left money on the
table
i missed out on some monetization
opportunities uh let me know we're at 99
likes
coffee with canal sell it 100.
okay we did it we did it stream focus we
did it living quite simply hey i
appreciate y'all
grateful that we could hang out before
my life changes forever
and uh my first um
baby hits the scene did you hear that
i said the first i was like babe i'm
excited to get to four here is
as quick as possible lewis is going to
be getting better at affiliate marketing
thanks so much uh lewis for saying
uh for taking action and and dropping
your aha moment
what is one of your aha moments uh
today uh and lena asks
how should we move forward feeling a
little lost uh
and lena i recommend checking out the
think marketing podcast and
we are about to go into season two in a
couple weeks and so we're taking a
couple weeks off
um to uh prepare some really new
powerful content but we have about 35
episodes
so i recommend as you're going on walks
as you're
um working out as you're doing chores as
you've got some time
pop in some headphones jump on spotify
jump on apple podcast
or google wherever you listen to
podcasts or if you don't listen to
podcasts yet check it out
and listen to the past episodes because
if you're feeling lost it's very normal
there's so much opportunity it's almost
like opportunity overwhelm
where do i fit in what is my what am i
what am i specifically going to do
i really believe that kind of like
taking a safari
through the online marketing content
creation
world and just being like my gosh
there's zebras and there's elephants and
there's drafts it's like wow there's
affiliate marketing there's online
courses there's youtube channels
there's podcasts there's tick-tock what
do i do well first go on a safari and
just get familiar with the landscape
and one of the best ways to do that is
to go through and listen to um
the season one of the think marketing
podcast and those thirst
first 35 episodes obviously not all at
once
um if you want you know some more help
of course
and you know that you're ready to be
you're ready to go to the next level
you're serious and you just need like
how could think media help me what are
what products and programs or the
monthly coaching program go to talk with
think.com
and uh um talk to someone on the think
media team and we definitely will give
you
uh some more uh we would love to help
you and figure out how we can help you
reach your goals
uh faster and again i want to thank you
so much for uh being a part of the
stream justin says i need to build an
online course for teaching creative
writing
that's a clear vision
justin and i appreciate you and thank
you so much for being here
today michelle says i need to learn how
to update my website and build my
mailing list clarity is power
and so it's um awesome to know what your
next steps are but if you don't
just stay in it just keep learning keep
reading keep listening
keep showing up uh if you don't quit you
win
and there is a lot to learn fight
overwhelm and just take it
one step at a time
i want to thank you for um being a part
of
the show today and i imagine next time
we'll be hanging out
i'm going to have uh a little baby
that'll be holding up like the lion king
like right holding up the baby and uh
we'll christen him on a coffee with
kennel what
are we talking about appreciate you
smash like if you got value today
thanks so much for being a part of the
think media community links in the
description down below or
in the facebook comments if you need uh